hi this is Sal Khan founder of the Khan  Academy and I'm just here to remind  everyone watching that Khan Academy is a  not-for-profit organization which means  no one owns Khan Academy we are a public  charity and we are dependent on  donations and donations from folks like  you are what allow us to create the  content and the interactive software  that you and folks like you use and so I  encourage you to think of making a  donation even a few dollars from  everyone watching this video would cover  Khan Academy's costs for the coming year  we're a small team here it kind of had  me under a hundred folks and we're  literally reaching tens of millions of  people every month and so the social  return on investment here is quite high  so once again really encourage you to  consider donating even a few dollars  thank you